all right Cassie
Cassie oh where are you from originally
I am originally from Brooklyn New York
tell me about your family my family is
from an island called Trinidad and
Tobago
um
in the
like
black community and then the
afro-caribbean community mental illness
isn't really something that's talked
about
um so
yeah
um I wasn't so
I have um autism and anti-social
personality disorder
and I wasn't diagnosed until I was 25
years old
um and that was after
a
breakdown basically
to tell me I assume that autism and
anti-social personality disorder there's
probably some overlap with those yeah
yes there is overlap that no one is
really talking about
which is part of the reason why I wanted
to do this interview
um so I was masking my autism
um for 25 years until I was diagnosed
and the psychiatrist that I was seeing
basically told me that because I was
masking my autism for so long as a
result
that's why I developed this Personality
Disorder
so long story short
um
I'm gonna go deep
okay so long story short I was sexually
assaulted at the age of nine years old
and after that happened that's when I
started
suppressing my emotions to cope with the
trauma of of being sexually assaulted
and I think one of the reasons why I was
a target for that person is because I
was clearly autistic like now that I'm
adult now that I'm an adult looking back
on my childhood I had clear signs of
autism
um and this person saw like a slow you
know
girl and took advantage
um
and yeah that's um I guess that's when
my personality started my personality
disorder started to develop
um because I I had no way of
coping with it especially since I had
autism because I would like scream and I
would cry even before the assault I
would have like
um like autistic meltdowns what I now
know to be autistic meltdowns back then
um
I guess like I was just like a very
unhappy child
um but yeah
sorry this is a lot to talk about
um describe the behavior of like your
your autism as well as your antisocial
personality disorder okay I'm like for a
friend or somebody that's meeting you
how does it play out how is your
behavior different than a normal person
okay so um so from what I was told by
like therapists and psychiatrists
um my brain works differently than a
normal person's brain I have a
neurodivergent brain a normal a normal
person has a neurotypical brain
um
so for me being a neurodivergent person
I see things differently
um and uh that like with the autism
basically like
um I'm just like I don't understand body
language
um after I was diagnosed at 25 I started
um reading books on body language and
watching YouTube videos on body language
um because for 25 years like I was just
going around not understanding body
language not knowing how to communicate
with people I was severely bullied in
school
um I I grew up in the early 2000s so
nowadays there's like a zero tolerance
for bullying but back then I used to get
spit on kids used to throw me downstairs
they would call me like a stupid n-word
stuff like that
um so uh yeah I was like um I was
bullied because of uh because I had
autism but I didn't know that I had
autism so I was thinking like every
single day I was thinking like what is
wrong with me like why am I so stupid
like why can't I understand people
um so that's
um like so that with autism so with the
anti-social personality disorder
um
because
um my only coping mechanism for dealing
with my autistic behavior
um was uh suppressing my emotions
um
I would stare at people because I didn't
understand people
um and I would try to like mimic like
what other girls were doing
um and they would look at me like what
the [__] is she doing and that was just
me trying to be normal
um uh but I was failing obviously
because I got bullied
um
but yeah like um when people think of
anti-social personality disorder they
think of like Dexter
I'm not like Dexter when people think of
autism they think of like Sheldon Cooper
um maybe I'm a little bit like Sheldon
Cooper
um but like
girls like me like when I was younger I
was a know-it-all but like I learned
really quick that I could not be a
know-it-all because
um I would
it was just like
like who do you think you are you know
um like even like I would I would read
the science book and I would read ahead
of the teacher and if the teacher got
something wrong then I'd be like oh
actually it's dioxy ribonucleic acid and
they just like look at me like you know
like I'm the teacher you're the student
like but um yeah
um I had to like pretend
to be like dumber than I was in school
because
um I didn't want to get bullied and
um the teachers thought I was annoying
so um
so yeah and that's like like now that I
like I am I know that I have autism
um I'm kind of like
um jealous of um autistic men because
they seem to be way further in life than
I am because they were diagnosed as a
kid they were able to get like the
support and the help that they needed as
a child
um and I know well I'm not friends with
them anymore but I know two guys that
had autism and um anti-social
personality disorder one
um was in medical school and the other
one is a paralegal
um and um I am unemployed so
um yeah like that kind of like
infuriates me a little bit because um
uh I keep on thinking like if I was
diagnosed earlier in life like who could
I have like like who could I have been
you know like what could I have done
with my life like who knows maybe I
would have been like a paralegal or um
or like in medical school you know
um so yeah like after the age of 25
um I I was like okay
um it sucks yeah after I was diagnosed
um I was like okay it sucks that I have
this but like at least I know what's
wrong with me because I didn't know what
was wrong with me
um and then also
um
like my psychiatrist was explaining to
me that um uh sociopathy is on a
spectrum right so
um when people say like oh sociopaths
can't feel feelings
um we can I just view feelings through a
cognitive lens
um like I um what is it called
uh I intellectualize feelings because um
I suppressed my feelings from the age of
nine years old to 25
so
um yeah like I can't I can't feel things
as intensely as a neurotypical person
would
um so
uh
sorry I'm trying to think because like
I'm go I didn't have anything like like
so I'm like okay what do I talk about
next um
so yeah so
so can I feel feelings
um yes and no
so
um
like like okay so this is a good example
so me and my friend we were watching TV
and there's this like commercial with
the dogs right and the dog has like one
leg and my friend is like oh my God like
that's so sad and wants to turn it off
right and in my mind like I don't feel
that instant like oh my God that's so
sad in my mind I'm like the dog has
three legs
dogs usually have four legs it's
probably difficult for the dog to walk
around that's sad so like I have to like
think about like feelings
um I don't just like feel them and um
that sucks because like the only
feelings that I've been like able to
feel like intensely have been depression
loneliness
and um anger so like the only
um the only like uh feelings that I like
like I could say like I feel I like the
bad ones
um which uh is not something that I like
um because I would like to feel happy I
would like to feel love
um and like me and my psychiatrist at
the time were we were thinking we were
like talking about it and like um I was
like you know I I want to be capable of
Love be I want to know what love feels
like
um I've never been in love
um but like I'm not going to say oh
because I have anti-social personality
disorder I can't love you know because
like
I I watch Like romantic movies and like
I wanna um I wanna like feel that but I
haven't and I'm 30 years old
so yeah
sorry are there doctors kind of
described any Medicare are there
medications even for autism there's not
right
um so for autism spectrum disorder
there's medications to like deal with
the the side effects that come with like
having that the stress that comes with
having that but there's no from what I
know there's no real medication for
autism
um and I don't think there's an FDA
approved medication for anti-social
personality disorder because it's a
personality disorder so you're not on
any medications I'm on antidepressants
I'm currently on antidepressants
um because I get depressed a lot
um and this is this is another thing
like
like so like um so those girls in school
right
um like they'd be like why is this [__]
staring at me like she's weird and it's
like I I was like trying to like like um
understand like okay like how to be
normal
how to fit in right because like because
I have anti-social personality disorder
like I I automatically like um because I
don't I can't read body language so like
I have to like um like when I look at a
person I look at like who they present
to be and then I try to figure out who
they actually are right so
um so like I'm psychoanalyzing every
single person I meet not because I want
to it's kind of like
um like a survival Instinct because I um
because I was sexually assaulted as a
child not not just once but like
multiple times so like I am
like like I I psychoanalyze everyone I
meet and um
and and I have to but like when people
like realize well I try I try to do it
in a way that they don't like like they
don't know that I'm doing it like that
um
but yeah like when people realize that I
am like uh doing that then they feel
uncomfortable they feel vulnerable and
like I don't want people to feel like
that around me but like
what am I gonna do like I
I um I have a hard time feeling emotions
like and like
[Music]
um
there's such a stigma that comes with
antisocial personality disorder because
when you hear the word sociopath you
think of criminals you think of um
like Killers like I don't want to kill
anyone and I'm not a criminal
um
yeah do you have friends
uh my roommate is my only friend
um have you been in love no
I've never been in love I want to be in
love but I've never been in love
um
and how old are you I'm 30. yeah
yeah I oh and um I made a tick tock
um which is my only Tick Tock at the
moment because I was on a dating app and
a guy called me a femcel which is a
female involuntary celibate which is
like a playoff of incel right and
um I was thinking about it and I'm like
the only sexual sexual experience that I
have has been
um non-consensual like and so like am I
a femcel because but in cells they um
they they for them it's just like oh I
can't get any sex you know for me it's
like it's it's not like like obviously
I'm female like
it wouldn't be hard to to get that or
whatever but for me like I want to find
someone that I can feel safe around
um someone that can be understanding of
my disorders the autism and the um um
antisocial personality disorder
um and uh I have not found that because
guys think like oh you're crazy and they
just like don't want to be with a crazy
person and it's not that I want to be
crazy I obviously don't want to be crazy
um and I I try to hide my crazy very
well which is unique and different yeah
exactly
um
but like um but yeah like I can't I I
have to
um
what's it called
I have to look at feelings like I have
to think about feelings I don't just
like feel feelings
um and that's very stressful
um that it just doesn't come naturally
to me
um and it's it's very annoying that when
I tell people about my disorder they
automatically ghost me because they
think I'm going to manipulate them or
they think that like I um I'm capable of
doing like bad things because they're
like oh well if you can't feel like how
do I know that you're not gonna stab me
and I'm just like well I'm not going to
stab you because that would be a bad
thing and I'm not a bad person I think I
think anti-social personality disorder
gets a really bad name because everyone
thinks you're you're ought to stab or
kill them yeah yeah and I get it no you
know what I can't now that like I
understand where people are coming from
like I get it like like if if someone is
stare like if I was a man if I was a
male I would probably be addicted to
drugs or I'd be dead like honestly
speaking if I was a black man with the
same disorder that I have now
um
yeah because like I am look when I was
living in New York City uh one of my
hobbies was people watching and that
like most people would be like that's
creepy but like for me that's how I
learned to like uh
to to be normal by watching people
um but people don't like to be watched
so yeah
um
yeah
what is the hardest part of all of this
for you just the loneliness
um the loneliness is the hardest part
because when people think of loneliness
they think like like oh like you want a
boyfriend like no it's not just that
it's the fact that even like girls don't
feel comfortable around me because like
like like as as the women as girls like
I feel like we're automatically like
nurturers and empathetic and stuff like
that and so like the fact that like I
have to think before like being empath
like to me empathy is cognitive like I
have to think like I don't treat people
the way that I would want to be treated
I treat people the way I think they
would want to be treated so like there's
so many steps when it comes to empathy
for me because
um it doesn't come naturally but like I
refuse to be labeled as someone that
can't be empathetic so like
it's um it's very very difficult very
difficult so the loneliness is a huge
thing that is making me depressed
um that's why I'm on antidepressants
um because I'm 30 years old I have no
boyfriend I have no friends my family
even feels uncomfortable around me no
I'm not working and that's another
that's another thing like
like it really really sucks because like
my my mom she was like oh you were so
smart in school and it's like well yeah
oh well actually I can't talk I can't
say anything bad about my mom because I
love her God bless her heart
um she she's she's from Trinidad and
they they don't they don't go to
therapists you know they don't they
don't like so so I can't be mad at my
mom she did the best that she could
um with with what she knew at the time
so
you don't have kids I assume no I don't
have any kids
um yeah and I want kids that's the thing
like out in a perfect world I would love
to be married with kids have a bunch of
friends have a good job be able to pick
up on social cues like in a perfect
world I would love to not be labeled as
a sociopath like that would be like
amazing
[Music]
um
and another thing too
um I can't find a therapist to stick
with me
um so like so here I am right like like
a diagnose someone with with autism and
anti-social personality disorder and I'm
saying like hey I would like to find a
therapist to help me because I'm having
difficulty in life and um they see my
psyche vowel and the ones that are
willing to help me
um when when we have a therapy session
like recently I had a therapy session
with um with a therapist that dropped me
and
um like she basically said like like I
like it's it's so complicated and it's
so much work to like to like help you
because like um like with sexual assault
because I'm part of the reason why I'm
also going to therapy is so that I can
get help with the trauma that comes with
that because like as someone with aspd I
don't um so uh I didn't process the
assault like like a neurotypical woman
would have in my mind
I just said like this person is a
monster they took advantage of me and
um that's [__] up right but like my
body like like I can I can compart
compartmentalize it in my mind but my
body is still not over it because
sometimes like I wake up and my eyes are
wet because I was crying in my sleep
um and so I'm like oh my gosh like I
don't want to be crying in my sleep like
like I need to get help
um and I was talking to her about it and
um
she basically said that like she
couldn't help me and she referred me to
like another therapist
um because like she she didn't know like
how to go about helping me uh because of
my personality diagnosis
yeah I don't even know if I said that
right I don't know if anything I'm
saying is making sense
but yeah
have you had multiple therapists
I have had several therapists oh my god
um I I have had
um in my life probably about a dozen
therapists in the past five years
that's a lot right
your last one dropped you
she did she did because like and you
know bless her heart like she tried
um but like um I think she got a little
creeped out because like like
I'm saying like like this is affecting
me and she's like well how do you feel
about it and I'm like well I I'm
indifferent towards it like like that
person is [__] up you know but so it's
like how do you treat somebody
who has to think about
like emotions how do you treat someone
that doesn't just say like oh I feel
like sad like I can say I feel sad but
for me or I can say I feel depressed but
for me it's different because like like
for depressed for for most people they
they're like oh I feel like I feel the
depression for me
um I'm thinking about like all the
things that happened to me in my mind
and it's intrusive thoughts so like like
it won't go away so the thoughts won't
go away and because the thoughts won't
go away
um I'm either overeating or like
watching Netflix and then waking up and
my eyes being wet from crying in my
sleep or like sometimes I'm in the
shower and like I just like turn on the
hot water because I'm like oh I'm dirty
like I need to I need to be cleaned so
so so like for me like feelings
um
they're they're different
they're they're different because like
I view them differently
so and and therapists don't know how to
treat that they're like
how how do we go about helping you and
I'm just like I don't know you're the
therapist you tell me is that the
hardest part of of these disorders is
your inability to just
straight feel feeling so you have to
like process and think about it so so
from so I don't like I'm not like a
psychiatrist or whatever but from what I
was told from the psychiatrist that
diagnosed me
um is that um
what was your question I'm so sorry it
seems like the most difficult part of
all this that you just can't feel a
feeling yeah like most of us would yeah
you have to process it and think about
it
yeah maybe just yeah yeah I found it
before you can express any emotions
exactly exactly and um
yeah
that's that's pretty much it I mean
but it was with a partner or a friend
who can understand that maybe has some
similar
behaviors maybe it could that oh oh my
gosh so I have to talk about this but I
don't can I say names or no that's bad
right
um
okay so I'll I'll just I'll just I won't
say their names because I but um but
okay so with the the Indian guy right
the parent um sorry the guy that went to
medical school right so with him like he
he was always calling himself a winner
and like
um like his he used his sociopathy like
like to get ahead in life right so it
wasn't like when you say the Indian guy
did you refer to him earlier
oh did I did I say his name I don't
think you no you didn't but oh the two
guys that I knew that had autism and um
anti-social personality disorder one was
Indian one was white I don't want to say
their names that's why I'm referring to
them by race but maybe I shouldn't refer
to them by race I apologize if that's
offensive
um but yeah like
um like with him like like he he used it
to his Advantage so for me it's a
disability but for him
um it was like a superpower you know and
um the same thing with um the dude that
was a paralegal like him like he he he
used his sociopathy to his advantage and
um he was very well I don't know him
anymore well because we don't talk but
like like he was he was successful
um and it just sucks because like
like if I if I were to lean into like
those like dark Triad traits like
because I like I have to like like uh
like take extra steps to not be a [__]
and to not be an [__] right
um because like as a female like as a
woman if I leaned into my sociopathy
um someone would either curse me out or
like beat me up
um because those traits are not like
um valued in women the same way they are
valued in men
um so
yeah
I'm so sorry I'm like I'm rambling and I
I can't really like um like
like I forgot the question because I
feel it that's your autism yeah like oh
I'm very forgetful because I'm
constantly thinking like I'm like there
are thoughts like going through my head
like all the time what advice would you
give to someone who's got similar
problems this year
um
well is this someone that is undiagnosed
there's someone that might think they
have it or someone that that knows that
they have it any of you above the advice
that I would give someone
um is to uh not that you've solved all
your problems yet oh I have a plethora
of problems that have not been solved
um but the advice that I would give
someone is to
um
try I know it's hard I know the struggle
is real
but you can't give up on yourself you
have to try your your more than your
autism you're more than whatever
personality disorder you have
um
and that's what I've been doing I've
been trying so hard to be uh normal like
to be like a regular human
um
and um and I will try till the day that
I die to not be uh like someone that
like people look at and think what's
wrong with that person you know like I
want to be like someone that can like go
through Society peacefully because I've
had people threaten to kill me and I um
and I didn't I like uh all I was doing
was being myself basically and they were
uncomfortable around me
um and they they threatened to kill me
that they're into beat me up and like
um even like a flight or flight like
instincts I had to like develop over
time
um like
I I had people because I was getting
beat up so much in school like people
were just like beating the [__] out of
me in in schools So like
um
I don't know if I should talk about this
can I talk about like really can I can I
say like names and stuff or or I would
take them out if it's a problem okay all
right so um so I remember that I just
used first names anyway first names okay
um so yeah so like I remember
um I was so I at some point in my life I
was homeless
um and I refused to be on the streets so
I went into a like shelter it was like
an LGBT shelter in the Bronx and they
put me in a room that was predominantly
female
um and in this room I the first night
that I was there there was this girl and
she was super funny and she said a joke
and everyone in the room laughed
and um
I was the only one that didn't laugh so
I decided okay I'm have to act normal
and I laughed and then when I laughed
like everyone stopped laughing and they
started staring at me
um and then I left because
um I knew that it wasn't like a good
thing
um and then I came back like maybe like
an hour or two later and there was trash
on my bed and I just cleaned the trash
off and I went to sleep and the next
morning one of the girls came up to me
and she said you're a fake [__] we
don't want you in here
and um
it clicked that like crap they knew that
that was a fake laugh
and um because I I'm always masking uh
like uh because if I don't then people
feel uncomfortable and when people feel
uncomfortable they might say or do
things that they wouldn't do if they
were comfortable
um so yeah so she called me a fake [__]
and um I was like okay I'm sorry for
being a fake [__]
um and I stayed in that room for like a
couple months and like the girls would
curse me out they would threaten to beat
the [__] out of me
um and because like
I
kind of like so for me I'm used I I I'm
cut well I was used to being bullied and
abused so
um one of the girls that threatened to
like she came up to me and she was like
you know threatening to beat the [__]
out of me I was like okay just don't
kill me
because uh like if you're gonna do it
just do it and then she took a step back
and she was like
um this [__] she said this [__] is
crazy
I'm I'm not going to go to to jail for
your dumb ass right that's what she told
me
um and then
um the other girl was like no she's not
crazy she's a sociopath and that was the
first time anyone has ever called me a
sociopath was when I was in that shelter
um
and I was like
they know
um because like I I thought like I was
doing my best to like pretend to be
normal because like I at that time I was
homeless and I didn't want to be on the
streets
um and so a week later a staff member
came to me and um they said well the
staff member basically said um that the
girl came up to her and said that I was
um I was making her feel uncomfortable
and that she was scared that I was going
to kill her
and she was the one that threatened to
beat my ass and I was the one that was
saying okay beat my ass just don't kill
me but because I said that and that's
not something a normal person would say
she felt like
weird it out or whatever
um so
they put me in a in a one person in a
single person room
um because
um I guess like I was like uh I was just
they didn't want me in that room anymore
and then the weird this like the messed
up part is like I liked being in that
room like I liked being around people
and then when I was by myself like
that that made my mental health worse
um
but yeah that's when I realized like
okay
I have to accept being by myself because
I don't want to get my ass beat
um but it just sucks because like people
say that people with antisocial
personality disorder don't have empathy
but then like how are you going to say
that and then not even be understanding
or empathetic of the person with the
disorder
and I'm trying so hard to be empathetic
towards everyone that I meet and I'm
trying so hard to mask my autism and
people aren't trying to understand me at
all
and um
yeah and and that that um that's very
like very
um
it just like makes me angry
but like I don't want to be angry
because the people that like if like the
people my people that are acquaintances
around me they're like oh she's such a
nice person blah blah blah but the
people that are close to me they they
see the effects of like me having to
like you know mask all day mask my
autism mask my aspd and then like I'm
I'm home and like I'm screaming and I'm
crying and like like I'm saying like
leave me alone and like they're the ones
like that have to deal with it and it
sucks because like I wish that I had
coping mechanisms to deal with it to
deal with like my issues rather than
suppressing my emotions
um because the longer that I do that the
longer that it will be that like
um maybe one day like I won't feel
anything at all like sometimes I'm
scared that because because when I was a
teenager there were days that I felt
absolutely nothing and I and it was like
like for a normal person it's probably
like when you wake up in the morning and
you're sleepy and you just like like
like walking around like that's how I
was for like sometimes I'd be like that
for days sometimes I'd be like that for
weeks and um and it sucks because I
don't want to have autism and I sure as
hell don't want to have aspd but I have
those things and when therapists um
are afraid to
to take me as a client
um
it it's it's it hurts and it sucks
because how am I supposed to become a
productive member of society when I
can't get help and I'm poor I can't pay
out of pocket the last therapist I had I
had to pay eight hundred dollars
that that was basically all the little
money that I was saving up right so
um yeah like
the struggle is real that's basically it
I feel like I'm just ranting that's
right all right Cassie thank you so much
for sharing your story I wish you lots
of luck thank you getting yourself and
others to understand your problem thank
you thank you very much okay